just listening to a podcast actually
about this community organizing group in
Chicago that's basically trying to
intercede with exactly we're talking
about what what what is the difference
in reaction like if you can have one
second to think because in Chicago you
know they have a huge murder problem and
it's all these kids that are that are
basically shooting each other over the
moment it's done
they're like I just murdered a person
over a [ __ ] Mountain Dew and and a
you know a thermos and like I just want
that one second of my life back and
they're trying to do like community
intervention to help people with that
like that's second between reaction and
action it's like that is my that is my
worst spot when I'm disrespected in any
way I'm like I go [ __ ] apoplectic
dude me too I was driving with Natasha
we flew back from somewhere and we we
were at LAX and this uber pulled up and
our uber pulled up and I could tell what
we were getting in the car this guy
hates us like I could just feel it I
knew it he was like a older white dude
like he looked like a duck huh he was
like old like 55 60 look like a jazz
professor like he had like Pepitone
about very skinny and tall oh right just
like like David Taylor Kirk Fox as an
old man okay and but dorky and he like
he hated us I could feel it and to be
fair we were both wearing two hats
because we brought too many hats so I
could see why he hated us I was just
like oh this guy like thinks were like
hipster scum or something yeah I feel it
and the energy was you are but ya know
not everybody hates and we were we had
just watched the movie Midnight Cowboy I
love that on the on the flight over yeah
that's the that's a Jon Voight yes and
doesn't happen and we're like talking
about the from the film on the way back
and like you know it was like oh they
were they in a gay relationship or what
was it was a psychological walking here
walking over here you could feel the
uber driver just like oh just couldn't
even stand us and we got to our house I
should have been by the way immediately
when I noticed his energy been like
let's get a different car but I didn't
so we're getting close to the house and
I'm like oh this is a turn only lane you
want to get
into your into your left lane any site
it gets in the left lane and then I'm
like okay turn left here at my house and
he's like then he loses it this is
literally the only interaction we had
with him he's like I [ __ ] know what
I'm doing okay
and I go okay pull the [ __ ] car over
right now like I'm like snapping right
and he's just like [ __ ] you and he pulls
over and and I'm like I'm like screaming
he's screaming at me he's like you
[ __ ] jackass and I start recording
which is always a way to calm things if
you're ever in a conflict if you start
recording everything calms him down in
my game everybody's have a record record
so he's like he goes hi I'm I'm not a
pop the trunk [ __ ] I'm getting my
luggage and he's like I'm not giving you
your luggage I'm calling the police
and I'm like for [ __ ] what you
[ __ ] like what and I'm like and
Natasha's pregnant she's like nine
months pregnant it's like well I think
we were flying back from our special
actually which was her last her last
flight before she could before she
couldn't fly anymore so she's like
demonstrative ly pregnant and I'm
[ __ ] losing my mind
I'm not giving my [ __ ] luggage or
like you know just give me my luggage
give me my luggage he's like no I'm
calling the police
and I go Natasha jump in the car and pop
is she's pregnant and I'm like please
stop and I'm like get away from me
that's how I know these are two signs
that I am out of control is if I'm
screaming at Natasha when she tries to
stop it or if I mentioned that I grew up
in Oakland
very bad situation
pop I'm telling a pregnant woman like
hop in do a [ __ ] stunt like jump into
a car pop and so finally he goes off
he's calling the police I don't know why
and I run and I jump in and I pop the
trunk and he runs back over slams the
card like I'm like I don't know what I'm
gonna do here like I don't know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna like beat this old
man's ass like I'm gonna I just don't
know what to do and somehow Natasha
comes a situation down enough that he
gets the he gets the that somehow takes
our luggage out and I grab it and I'm
like I'm like all right I got my blog
it's not get the [ __ ] off my property
[ __ ] also you know I if you mentioned
your property yeah bad bad white that's
a white person my property I own this
and he's like I'm not going anywhere I'm
calling the police
I'm gonna wait till the police get here
and I go and they [ __ ] tell them what
man and he goes I'm gonna tell them you
guys are [ __ ] idiots and I go yeah
I'm sure they'll arrest us for being
idiots and he goes yeah and I'm gonna
tell him and I'm gonna tell him that you
didn't understand the plot to Midnight
Cowboy I was like okay you win I think
you win did you really say that I swear
to God I guess so and I just go like you
know what as a claw got a respects
[Laughter]
reading when you first movies reading on
uber oh that's a good question I don't
know you gotta check that I didn't even
look but I will tell you your boy did
not pay for that ride definitely contact
Eber that was my first my go-to no I I
complained to corporate but then it's
like ubers are crazy right because they
dropped you off at their house I mean if
a man is willing yeah get into a near
physical altercation when they over the
plot of Midnight Cowboy yeah like is he
not willing to come back and shoot my
place up yeah you gotta be careful
though yeah scary so all I should have
done all I should have done a real low
note what could you have done different
in that situation I know what I'm
[ __ ] doing